cuáles son los límites del humor esta
pregunta nos la estáis haciendo mucho a
los humoristas últimamente demasiado
para mi gusto para responder bien a esta
pregunta antes que nada habría que
consensuar una definición de humor que
habrá casi todos los tipos de humor que
no son pocos nosotros llegaríamos a una
definición de humor muy genérica muy
abstracta y a continuación tendríamos
que hablar de los límites abstractos de
esta definición abstracta y llegaríamos
a la respuesta posiblemente muy válida
pero pero que no serviría muy poco a la
hora de aplicarla a las formas de humor
más estrechas más más íntimas más
cercanas a nuestro a nuestro día a día
así que para responder a la dichosa
pregunta me vais a dejar que haga que
haga un truco y es que cambie la
pregunta en vez de cuáles son los
límites del humor primeramente voy a
responder
a cuándo y por qué un chiste nos sale
bien en vez de ir de lo genérico a lo
concreto creo que es mucho más
ilustrativo ir de lo concreto a lo
genérico vale entonces por ejemplo un
chiste
no sale bien cuando el receptor es decir
el público los lectores la audiencia los
telespectadores concia cuando el
receptor
desconoce los referentes presentes en el
chiste el humorista presupone que tú sí
que conoces esos referentes y esto no se
da y entonces el chiste falla un ejemplo
intentar explicarle contarle un chiste
de pokemon a vuestro abuelo veréis el
resultado no
un chiste no sale bien por ejemplo
cuando el receptor lo interpreta de
forma literal vale sin pararse a pensar
pues dobles sentidos ironías
digamos sentidos más allá de lo literal
no
el humorista presupone que tu gastar un
poco alerta que va a estar en guardia
que vas a captar esos sentidos figurados
esas ironías si esto no pasa el chiste
falla hay un ejemplo que a mí me parece
perfecto una de las grandes comedias de
hollywood de los 90 que es starship
troopers del director paul verhoeven
pues bien es una es una película muy
incomprendida que si tú digamos estás
alerta y pillas la ironía es un alegato
antibelicista pero si te la comes con
patatas sin tener ese sentido de la
ironía alerta básicamente lo que
interpretará será un panfleto fascista
así que bueno son esos casos donde están
alerta es bastante importante más casos
es un chiste no sale bien cuando
requiere del espectador que haga una
asociación de ideas muy compleja y en
muy poco tiempo vale
el humorista plantea un rompecabezas
presupone que el receptor va a ser capaz
de resolverlo si esto no se da
el chiste falla vale también se da a la
inversa un chiste no sale bien cuando el
receptor está esperando del humorista
mucha más audacia mucho más ingenio un
giro mucho más sorprendente cuando el
chiste es muy previsible por parte del
receptor pues ese chiste falla un
ejemplo
sabes que café vale no os habéis reído
nos ha pedido por supuesto porque si
hubiese reído significaría que estáis
cursando cuarto de parvulitos vale
entonces digamos que eso cuando cuando
digamos es muy obvio el remate de un
chiste cuando todo el mundo se lo espera
el chiste falla vale otro caso
importantísimo un chiste no sale bien
cuando requiere que el receptor conozca
el contexto del chiste y esto no se da
es decir al principio hablamos de los
referentes no los referentes están
dentro del chiste pues bien el contexto
serían todas aquellas circunstancias que
rodean al chiste vale que no están en el
chiste pero que hacen falta para
entender el chiste un ejemplo muy claro
imaginaos que vais conduciendo ponéis la
radio vosotros nunca habéis escuchado el
programa la competencia de rakú vale y
en ese momento se oye la voz de seth
cavas time no sé para los que no
conozcáis el programa se trata de un
personaje de ficción muy reaccionario
muy desacomplejado que dice muchas
barbaridades tú la primera vez que
escuchas eso sin saber el contexto que
es un programa de humor etcétera sin
conocer al personaje bueno pues te
puedes llevar una sorpresa y bueno lo
interpretas como un humor
un chiste no sale bien por ejemplo
cuando tú como receptor lo percibes no
como humor sino como un ataque a tus
valores vale esto pasa mucho en
situaciones pues donde yo que sé estados
de opinión momentos históricos donde las
posturas están muy polarizadas vale
entonces cuál quién según qué temas
cualquier chiste digamos que se puede
llegar a interpretar como un ataque
contra contra nuestra postura entonces
cuando interpretamos que eso es un
ataque contra nuestros valores y la
persona el humorista es alguien que
pertenece dada esa situación de
polarización hablaríamos de trinchera
casi cuando esa persona está en el otro
lado de la trinchera es un adversario
ese chiste seguramente lo interpretamos
como un ataque vale y no nos va a hacer
ninguna gracia otro caso similar pero
pero algo diferente sería cuando ese
chiste es un ataque a nuestros valores
pero viene de alguien que forma parte
del mismo lado que nosotros que forma
parte de nuestro lado de la trinchera
entonces seguramente lo lo veremos como
algún tipo de autocrítica y es posible
que el chiste sí funcione vale eso ya
depende de de la sensible de la
sensibilidad de cada cual luego existe
un caso todavía más exagerado
parecido a este que un chiste no sale
bien cuando independientemente del
chiste digamos que el humorista nos
genera algún tipo de suspicacia aunque
por lo que está diciendo en el chiste no
no tiene por qué ir contra nuestros
valores si su persona si esa persona
creemos que es un adversario seguramente
dará igual el chiste que nos cuente
seguramente el chiste fallara vale hay
gente que indirectamente no nos hace
gracia imaginaos a vuestro mayor
adversario político contando un chiste
buenísimo o reír y aix pues seguramente
no vale y luego un chiste
nos sale bien cuando el receptor no
tiene ningún ánimo de reír por
circunstancias personales trágicas
normalmente transitorias sí que es
cierto que mucha gente digamos que se
sirve del humor para superar sus
desgracias personales pero en general
hay momentos en la vida tragedias
personales donde el humor nos sienta mal
sino si el humor en ese momento no toca
el chiste falla vale entonces repasando
un poco está esta casuística nos damos
caso nos damos cuenta de que la
efectividad de un chiste en general está
muy estrechamente relacionada con el
grado de conocimiento mutuo entre emisor
y receptor vale
cuanto menos se conoce en emisor y
receptor menos se aceptan emisor y
receptor más probabilidad hay de que el
chiste falle vale entonces habría como
dos grandes dos grandes casos no uno
sería hacer reír a una persona cercana a
un amigo una persona amiga vale esto en
realidad es bastante fácil no le quito
mérito pero
bastante fácil y luego el caso extremo
sería hacer reír a un público masivo
generalista eso que llamamos el gran
público vale eso es más difícil y porque
es más difícil es una profesión y los
humoristas profesionales nos dedicamos a
ello pero no es fácil la verdad es que
no es fácil hay que iu porque no es
fácil pues básicamente porque el gran
público
son obviedades pero hay que decirlas tú
no conoces uno por uno a todas las
personas que conforman el gran público y
esas personas entre sí son muy distintas
es decir es prácticamente matemático
algo tan importante como son los
referentes compartidos lo que decíamos
de los referentes cuanta más gente
compone una audiencia la intersección de
referentes los referentes compartidos se
va haciendo cada vez más pequeña vale
imaginaos por ejemplo un animador de
cruceros vale que tiene que hacer reír a
un público compuesto por parejas de la
tercera edad niños pequeños matrimonios
conservadores matrimonio
más progresistas buenas prácticas por la
borda es absolutamente imposible es muy
difícil hacer un chiste que haga reír
mucho a todo el mundo en mi opinión es
imposible lo que sí puedes hacer es
hacer un chiste que sea capaz de hacer
gracia a una mayoría y para para hacer
hacia una mayoría tienes que entender
que denominador común tiene esa mayoría
no tienes que de algún modo conocer a tu
público saber quién es adaptarte un poco
a ese público vale
entonces esto es lo que respecta a la
parte del humorista pero lo cierto es
que
el público no es tan pasivo como mucha
gente nos quiere hacer creer el público
también es capaz de poner parte de su
parte para bueno pues intentar entender
según qué formas de humor a las que
todavía no está habituado sí que es
cierto que un humorista desconocido para
el público pues es posible que el
público lo rechace porque precisamente
porque es desconocido pero del mismo
modo este humorista desconocido que es
desconocido
inicialmente puede digamos resultar un
misterio interesante el público en
realidad también quiere conocer también
le apetece no saber quién es quién es
esa persona y concede el beneficio de la
duda a los humoristas entonces digamos
que él
pongo un ejemplo dos amigos muy cercanos
vale se hacen una broma privada entre
ellos que prácticamente sólo pueden
entender ellos
una tercera persona notar amiga no tan
cercana escucha esa broma privada y
puede reaccionar de dos maneras puede
decir yo esto no lo pillo no es para mi
paso vale o puede decir no lo pillo no
es para mí pero
[Música]
entiendo por donde ganó intuyo por dónde
va me acoplo y por favor quiero más
hay como 22 perfiles
muy muy generales de humoristas uno
sería el que es muy considerado con su
audiencia el que intenta digamos
acercarse de forma perfectamente
calculada a la audiencia ese sería uno
no y otro sería aquel que bueno con su
broma privada de alguna manera con su
voz propia es capaz de conquistar poco a
poco una cosa que al principio parece
minoritaria pues poco a poco ir ganando
adeptos y digamos pues irse formando una
parroquia de seguidores sin renunciar
digamos a su a su a su autoría como como
humorista pues normalmente en el en el
mundo del humor profesional
esta reflexión que estoy haciendo es una
cosa analítica posterior y en general lo
que los humoristas profesionales hacen
es un acercamiento intuitivo no una
mezcla de detener tu voz propia que te
haga gracia a ti pero que no solo lo
entiendas tú y tus cuatro amigos que
pueda seducir que pueda gustar a más
gente vale entonces
digamos de algún modo en este estaría la
clave de la clave de todo
porque si la audiencia conoce bien al
humorista y el humorista conoce bien a
la audiencia
no existen límites para el humor
en definitiva los límites del humor son
el desconocimiento entre semejantes
el humor es una conversación
yo no entiendo quién eres y tú no
entiendes quién soy yo pues no tiene
sentido que sigamos conversando muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]